REMEMBER, BOTH WORKING IN
THE MUELLER SPECIAL COUNSEL
CASE.
BUT, FIRST, PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S ATTORNEY JAY SEKULOW
IS NOW CALLING FOR A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL APPOINTED TO
INVESTIGATE THE MASSIVE
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
SURROUNDING A KEY DEPARTMENT
NOW THE COMPANY BEHIND THE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
FAKE TRUMP ANTI-TRUMP
PROPAGANDA FROM RUSSIA,
WELL, THAT DOSSIER, THIS
COMES AFTER A FOX NEWS
EXCLUSIVE REPORT SHOWING
THAT IN FACT THE WIFE OF
BRUCE OHR, THE RECENTLY
DEMOTED DOJ OFFICIAL
ACTUALLY WORKED FOR FUSION
FAKE NEWS DOSSIER.
NOW, ALSO TONIGHT, THE FAKE
NEWS MEDIA ARE WORKING
OVERTIME BY SPREADING
OUTRIGHT LIES AND
MISINFORMATION TO TRY TO
DAMAGE AND DISCREDIT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE RECENT
EXAMPLES.
EMAIL ON SEPTEMBER THE 4TH,
2016, THAT GAVE HIM SPECIAL
ACCESS TO HACK DNC EMAILS
THAT WERE NOT RELEASED AT
THAT POINT BY WIKILEAKS.
THAT WAS A TOTAL LIE.
BECAUSE THE EMAIL WAS SENT
THAT WAS ACTUALLY SENT FROM
SEPTEMBER 1ST THAT WAS THE
DAY AFTER WIKILEAKS HAD
PUBLISHED THE DNC EMAILS.
ALSO FAKE MUST NEWS CNN WERE
PUSHING THAT STORY FOR HOURS
AND OTHERS LIKE CONSPIRACY
BEFORE THE CLINTON NEWS
NETWORK FINALLY OFFERED A
CORRECTION.
OVER THE WEEKEND "THE
FAKE NEWS PHOTO AND CLAIMED
THAT THE ARENA WAS EMPTY
DURING A TRUMP RALLY IN
FLORIDA.
TURNS OUT THE PHOTOS, WELL,
ON STAGE.
AND WEIGEL IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE WAS FORCED
TO APOLOGIZE.
IT WAS AN OUTRIGHT LIE.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" TOLD US
A STORY CLAIMING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WATCHES UP
TO 8 HOURS OF TV A DAY AND
DRINKS 12 DIET COAX.
HUGE NEWS.
CNN HAS SINCE BEEN USING
THAT SO-CALLED REPORT TO
WILDLY SPECULATE ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HEALTH AND
N. A PRETTY DESPICABLE
DISPLAY DISPLAY LAST WEEK
THAT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
AND HIS FAMILY'S BANK
RECORDS FROM DEUTSCHE BANK.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LEGAL
TEAM QUICKLY PUSHED BACK AND
BY THE WAY THOSE OUTLETS
ALSO ISSUED CORRECTIONS.
FINALLY, OF COURSE, THERE
WAS ABC NEWS' BRIAN ROSS.
HE WAS SUSPENDED WITHOUT PAY
FOR REPORTING THAT
LIEUTENANT GENERAL MICHAEL
FLYNN WAS PREPARED TO
TESTIFY THAT THEN CANDIDATE
TRUMP ORDERED HIM TO CONTACT
THE RUSSIANS.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE FALSE.
HE IS ALSO FORBIDDEN FOR
EVER REPORTING ON DONALD
TRUMP GOING FORWARD.
THE ATTORNEY FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP, JAY SEKULOW, YOU WERE
INVOLVED TODAY.
I ACTUALLY SAW YOUR TEXT
MESSAGES TO NBC.
>> YES.
>> Sean: WHERE YOU SAID YOU
ARE NOT CALLING FOR A
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO BE
APPOINTED FOR ROBERT MUELLER
AT ALL.
>> CORRECT.
>> Sean: YOU SAID IT THREE
TIMES IN THAT SAME TEXT
EXCHANGE.
>> RIGHT.
SO HERE'S WHAT YOU HAD.
SEAN, THIS WAS A REALLY
YESTERDAY ABOUT BRUCE OHR,
AND THE CONVERSATIONS HE HAD
WITH FUSION GPS AND CHRIS
STEELE, WHICH BY THE WAY
SUPPOSEDLY WERE DONE WITHOUT
KNOWLEDGE OF HIS -- THOSE IN
AUTHORITY OVER HERE AIM
AUTHORITY AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, WE THEN FIND OUT
THAT NOT ONLY MEETING WITH
FUSION GPS AND CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WHO WROTE THE FAKE
DOSSIER, BUT THAT, I MEAN,
YOU CANNOT MAKE THIS STUFF
UP.
THAT BRUCE OHR'S WIFE WAS
WORKING AT THE SAME TIME FOR
FUSION GPS AND WAS THEIR
EXPERT ON RUSSIA.
SO, WE SAID WHEN WE SAW THIS
YESTERDAY WITH MY COLLEAGUES
WE DISCUSSED THE ISSUE AND
DECIDED THAT THE BEST COURSE
OF ACTION HERE IN OUR VIEW
AS LAWYERS WAS THAT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL BE APPOINTED
GRAHAM HAS STATED TO LOOK
INTO ALL OF THIS.
AS I SAID IN MY STATEMENT,
BREATHTAKING IN SCOPE.
NOW, NBC GOUT THAT.
I WAS CLEAR AS YOU SAW THREE
TIMES IN EMAIL A TEXT
EXCHANGE WITH THE MAIN
REPORTER ON THIS AND NBC
SAYS THE STORY EXACTLY
OPPOSITE.
I SAID THIS IS NOTHING TO DO
WITH BOB MUELLER.
WE HAVE BEEN COOPERATING
I'M VERY ENCOURAGED AND I'M
VERY NOT ONLY ENCOURAGED, I
WILL TELL YOU THIS.
THIS HAS BEEN ONE
TRANSPARENT ADMINISTRATION
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT'S BEEN
DONE HERE.
AND WHAT'S BEEN PROVIDED TO
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
AND I'M VERY CONVINCED THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL CONCLUSION.
HAVING SAID THAT I NEVER
SAID A WORD, SEAN, NOT ONE
>> ABOUT A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> Sean: YOU SAID JUST THE
OPPOSITE, JAY.
>> EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE.
THEY DID IN SOME OF THEIR
NEWS REPORTS, BUT ONE OF THE
MSNBC HOSTS TOOK WHAT WAS
SAID INCORRECTLY BY NBC, RAN
ARE IT AND STILL TO THIS
MOMENT HAS NOT RETRACTED IT
ALTHOUGH HE HAS PUT MY FULL
STATEMENT IN.
PUT THAT ON TOP DEUTSCH BANK
THE FAKE PICTURE FROM THE
PACKED RALLY IN PENSACOLA,
THE INCORRECT STATEMENTS
SITUATION ON THOSE EMAILS
WITH WIKILEAKS AND GETTING
THE DATE WRONG WITH SUPPOSE
DOLLARSLY THREE SOURCES, I
WANT TO JUST TELL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TONIGHT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU WHAT
IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING HERE
AND YOU ARE SEEING IT IN,
UNFORTUNATELY, PLAY OUT
BEFORE YOUR EYES.
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS I AM
VERY ENCOURAGED THAT WE'LL
BE BRINGING THIS TO A
SUCCESSFUL CONCLUSION.
>> Sean: LET ME BRING UP
THIS BREAKING NEWS WE HAVE
TONIGHT.
LET ME SET THE TABLE A
LITTLE BIT.
WE KNOW BRUCE OHR.
LITERALLY FOUR DOORS DOWN
FROM ROSENSTEIN.
WE KNOW HE WAS MEETING WITH
FUSION GPS.
THE FIRM THAT WAS HIRED THEY
CAME UP WITH FOX DOSSIER AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE TO GET
BACKGROUND.
TURNS OUT HIS WIFE WORKED
FOR FUSION GPS.
HERE IS WHERE IT GETS WORSE.
PETER STRZOK AND HIS
GIRLFRIEND LISA PAIGE, BOTH
OF THEM WORKING IN JUST
PETER STRZOK IN PARTICULAR.
HE WAS IN THE DOSSIER CASE.
HE INTERVIEWED CHERYL MILLS.
HE INTERVIEWED HUMA ABEDIN.
HE INTERVIEWED HILLARY
CLINTON.
HE WAS THERE ARE TO THE
INTERVIEW WITH GENERAL
FLYNN.
IT SEEMED LIKE THE FBI ONLY
HAS ONE FULL-TIME EMPLOYEE
BECAUSE HE IS INVOLVED IN
ALL OF THIS.
I AM LOOKING AT THE TEXT
GIRLFRIEND IS CALLING DONALD
TRUMP A LOATHE SOME HUMAN
BEING.
WHERE THEY ARE PRAISING
HILLARY CLINTON, THESE ARE
AND FAIR INVESTIGATION OF
INDIVIDUALS.
NOW, WE KNOW IN THE CASE
HUMA ABEDIN AND CHERYL
MILLS, THEY BOTH LIED.
THEY WEREN'T CHARGED LIKE
GENERAL FLYNN.
IN OTHER WORDS WE HAVE A
CASE WHERE PETER STRZOK,
JAMES COMEY LITERALLY WERE
INTO HILLARY CLINTON'S
EMAIL.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT.
>> WELL, I MEAN, FIRST OF
CASE AND APPARENTLY ALTHOUGH
NONE OF US KNOW THIS FOR A
FACT, THIS WAS THE REASON.
SO THAT'S ONE QUESTION RIGHT
THERE.
HE WAS BY THE WAY ONE OF THE
LEADING COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
FBI AGENTS IN THE BUREAU.
STOOD HUMAN RESOURCES.
REASSIGNED
TO HUMAN LEE SOURCES.
CONCERNED ABOUT HIS ABILITY
TO MOVE FORWARD ON THIS AND
OBJECTIVE MANNER UNDER THE
LAW.
HERE, SEAN, THERE IS ANOTHER
ASPECT OF THIS THAT TENDS TO
GET OVERLOOKED.
16 WITNESSES WERE GIVEN
IMMUNITY BY THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IN THE
WHOLE INVESTIGATION ON THE
EMAILS.
AND HE WROTE THAT
EXONERATION LETTER BEFORE --
BEFORE THE INTERVIEWS OF
THOSENS WITHS TOOK PLACE.
SO, YOU KNOW, EXPLAIN THAT.
YOU CAN'T.
IN AND PETER STRZOK WAS
INVOLVED IN THIS.
BY THE WAY, GOD HILLARY
SHOULD WIN, YOU KNOW,
100 MILLION TO ZERO.
I GUESS WE KNOW WHERE
POLITICAL AFFILIATION LIES.
>> HERE'S THE BIGGEST POINT
FROM A LEGAL STANDPOINT HERE
SEAN HERE IS WHAT IS
SIGNIFICANT.
BECAUSE OF A PARENTALLY HE
IS REMOVED.
LOOK AT THE ISSUE IN A MORE
GLOBAL SENSE.
WHY IS IT THAT THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION,
THERE ARE A LOT OF GREAT
AGENTS OUT THERE.
WE KNOW THAT THAT PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE EVERY DAY
FOR ALL OF US, OUR FAMILIES.
WHY IS IT THAT WHEN YOU GO
BACK TO THE BRUCE OHR AND
DOSSIER.
DID THAT DOSSIER SERVE AS
>> Sean: GET AN ANSWER.
GREAT QUESTION.
>> WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET
A QUESTION THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OWES THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AN ANSWER ON THAT AND
GIVE IT FORTH WITH.
OF COURSE COCK IS SUBPOENAED
ANSWER ON ALL OF THESE
QUESTIONS.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A
MINUTE.
FISA WARRANT ISSUED ON A
DOSSIER THAT WAS WITH ALL OF
THIS INTERASPECTS GOING ON
HERE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU
HAVE TO SAY HOW IS THIS
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWER TO THAT IS?
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE WHEN YOU
SAY IT, BUT IT IS THE DEEP
STATE.
IT'S THE BUREAUCRATS.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT THEY
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT,
BECAUSE THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
OF IT?
THE PRESIDENT TALKING WITH
RUSSIANS.
MEETING WITH RUSSIANS.
MEETING WITH RUSSIAN -- ALL
THE RUSSIA TALK THAT'S TAKEN
PLACE NOW FOR A YEAR.
AS THIS HAS NOW BEEN, YOU
KNOW, FULLY VETTED.
THERE WAS NOTHING THERE.
>> Sean: HILLARY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
WITH RUSSIA LIES, PROPAGANDA
TO INFLUENCE THE 2016
ELECTION.
>> BUT TAKE IT RIGHT BACK
INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, SEAN.
AND HOW IS IT THAT THE
FOURTH RANKING DOJ OFFICIAL
IS -- WIFE WORKS FOR THE
COMPANY THAT'S PUTTING
TOGETHER THE DOSSIER.
AND THAT SHOULD JUST BE
OKAY?
BECAUSE THE MEDIA, BELIEVE
ME, THE MEDIA WOULD NOT HAVE
COVERED WHAT HAPPENED TODAY
ON THIS UNLESS NBC WOULD
HAVE PUT OUT THE INCORRECT
STATEMENT.
THIS WAS WOO HAVE GOTTEN NO
ATTENTION.
ALL.